SPEAKER 1: Hello everyone.
SPEAKER 2: Hi.
SPEAKER 3: Today's episode
is all about good times.
SPEAKER 4: First thing,
you need a Google account.
If you don't have one,
that's easy to fix.
SPEAKER 5: Doing
so will reward you
with a plethora of colors
and bars on your device.
SPEAKER 3: Engaging users
in an immersive, enjoyable
experience.
SPEAKER 2: To help you make
your graphics look their best.
SPEAKER 6: That
kind of intelligence
will be built
inside the software.
SPEAKER 7: Our
team here at Google
works closely with
app developers.
SPEAKER 8: What
kind of challenges
do you see developers
facing and what are we
doing to make
their lives easier?
SPEAKER 9: Great apps
engage all learners.
And so we did a very
simple web app that
lets you type in your address
and the age of your kid,
and it would tell
you which schools
you were eligible to attend.
SPEAKER 10: So you can
think of today's episode
as a little bit of extra credit.
SPEAKER 2: So how
does this help you?
SPEAKER 4: Let's take a look.
SPEAKER 3: Look.
That dinner reservation
is on my Google calendar
so I don't forget.
SPEAKER 11: These are things
that you can worry less about.
SPEAKER 9: But with a
fundamental understanding
of how the digital world works.
SPEAKER 3: Highlighting
what matters most to users.
SPEAKER 10: But I want to
show you something here.
SPEAKER 4: What if
I told you I was
going to do it without using a
database or a back-end server?
SPEAKER 8: Sounds
like a lot of fun.
SPEAKER 10: Whoa.
SPEAKER 5: This is the
type of technical minutia
that's worth knowing.
SPEAKER 9: They've
never before realized
how important geeks are.
SPEAKER 8: One billion active.
SPEAKER 11: Yes.
SPEAKER 9: And you'll end up
with a community of people
that you really enjoy
and feeling really
good about the work that
you guys can do together.
SPEAKER 3: Well, these
are just some ideas
of how to take good experiences
and making them great.
SPEAKER 4: So now we're done.
SPEAKER 5: Don't forget to join
our Google+ community as well.
SPEAKER 6: And make
software more intelligent.
SPEAKER 3: And Google
takes care of the rest.
SPEAKER 4: Thanks for watching.
SPEAKER 3: Hope we get an
opportunity to serve you again.